back for another episode of worth it
we're not just noodling around here but
we are covering noodles noodles we've
done many types of noodles in the past
pasta spaghetti ramen today we're
focusing on non Italian noodles in Los
Angeles today I'm worth it we're gonna
be trying three delicious noodle dishes
at three drastically different price
points to find out which noodle is the
most worth it at its price
okay so we're sticking and specifically
the Asian dishes the first place we're
going to where we going we're going to
allow sure noodle house to see Joe and
Ellen and we're having their wife's
special noodle dish so it's very very
sweet like the story is doing like this
it is actually a sweet story how did you
come to start this business together
if he comes my favorite noodle in LA it
was different than what you are used to
very different you want to keep the
original diorama home Shaanxi probably
northwest of China I'm curious how many
styles of noodle there are from your
hometown 1s solvent it's more than a
thousand different styles yeah that's a
lot yeah that cuts a year north on mower
to also and my hometown would make a lot
most the time we make it with the lamb
or beef soup actually it's very similar
like macaroni noodle
knife cut no though it's a flat under
big no dough that's another way you
order makes stir-fry we are focusing on
the wife's special noodle dish could you
tell us what is this story behind that
dish introduces the choice just a matter
what you're a woman our apartment yet
first-rate hunger order Carthon tiene
una taco what on the Union
mental palana pathology or conservation
of natural virtually couldn't meet all
the hot sure hold on her digital age
which is what I can't hear not sure if
you have the Ludo is called a holo style
as long and the thing note of the
machine push it to the positive
reactivate so it's very very fresh where
they only take two or three minutes to
cook eight the first assess the beef
tasting will be a little bit spicy on
the tomato with a go we just use tomato
fried with egg a little bit sour tasty
the ground pork justice I'm being paid
to withdraw the park if I'm
understanding this correctly in your
hometown it's common to eat each of
these sauces with noodles sometimes
people will combine two and you had the
idea to put all three together yeah why
was that the flavor will be more
conflict because I realize this together
and have a vegetable and meat have a
sour how the salty one bowl is great you
guys also make dumplings here do you
have a recommendation which one we
should try no lung
you at home I'm gonna do it with vinegar
and chili oil company cheers Cheers
yeah go to the baths together huh yeah
[Music]
right I have another share some with
that I don't there it is mmm won't won
any it's a very soft way I'm very light
yeah et hasn't had one actually the most
important thing about the sampling the
wrapper which is the same dough as the
noodles this is a lot of food this is a
fun amount
cheers Cheers mmm delicious noodle yeah
I always loved a noodle that you can
just stuff in your face already monsters
are here I see any going like this with
the headphones fries a lot of LARPing
going home
honestly I've never heard of tomato egg
before today this is kinda crazy because
it's like combining all these flavors
from my childhood it's all those things
it's like whoa like you can just like
[Music]
that's ratatouille I still haven't seen
that movie thousand types of noodles
aprox so comforting very very good
noodle dish before we go to our next
noodle place no no a place called Bistro
Naz that does Beijing specialty desserts
yes and this place is recommended by our
good friend Edie we want to finish that
before we is the biggest lady Susan I've
ever seen huge okay I said Edie where
should we get some desserts and she said
you have to go to bistro nas why is that
they have food from my hometown Beijing
I eat here a lot cure my homesick and
their dessert is something I grew up
eating so I figure you guys should try
Wow okay
so this is how a deal is I know exactly
what I want but I want to ask you D what
we should eat then dunk euro the donkey
roll yes okay do you want to start with
a donkey wrong that's not the best one
either you're wrong
this has to be a roll kind of guy before
we enjoy the rest of these deserts let's
enjoy a noodle fact no fact or your
noodle oh wow new or in all effects and
noodle facts yeah cuz they improve your
noodle yeah no I did that joke just now
the Chinese generally speaking don't dry
their pasta but Italians do I have never
made that distinction for a spaghetti
episode we saw spaghetti extruded but
they allowed it to dry before oiling
whereas at Lau sure it extruded straight
into the water I think it's because it's
not optimized for that al dente flavor
yet from drying it explains so much of
why I like John Hastie those more than
pasta yeah cuz they're just squishier
bushier yeah hmm so for our next noodle
stop we're going to Cebu Gras and
Dolan's weaker cuisine we're gonna be
trying there big plate chicken before we
have that we're gonna eat the rest of
these desserts okay so the camera let's
go to town
I like that hmm what is Weger cuisine
the VGO region is located as a middle
point of the Silk Road it's influenced
by the Persian Indian Turkish and
Chinese many people as you guys have
kept up and you guys have some what dish
how do you invented this but actually
this is original vigor for our chef
arcane gonna do all dishes today what
are the highlight dishes of whitter
cuisine in ancient time River people
will come up in the desert so you make a
fire and you make that power and its
shape is like that by polo is very
traditional raised rice and me
the Carroll reasons together Monte looks
like the Chinese dumpling but bigger the
dog is very thin it stuff it with beef
and onion spices so talking about the
big plate shake it so I imagine it's big
yes it's huge how this was a noodle
episode Andrew this is a noodle dish
right of course yeah it comes to snow
this is like very typical Chinese and
vigor fusion we fry the chicken with the
oil and peppers and spices cinnamon
cumin star any strand pepper so this is
spicy we put the potato and we braise up
another we also make the handmade noodle
modally itself should be chewy we make
the noodle with water salt and egg
whites egg whites in a question because
it makes it really chewy and it stick
model this is a difference between big
play chicken little bit the other model
use it should be thick and white I
notice with the big plate chicken all
the noodles are covered by the things on
top why are you trying to build this
mountain of meat on top of the noodles
because the big paycheck it has so so
when you eat a knodel mix it with the
soup
it's like amazing taste I've never seen
a teacup like this before all are
handmade Wow handmade yeah
flower tea this is very common in my
country this is also sort of my creation
Cheers
mmm here's all the tea mmm
oh yeah Rose just a minute here it's
cinnamon cardamom cardamom you ready for
some big plate chicken Steven big plate
chicken here we go my goodness okay we
got we got one noodle sticking out over
here okay should we start with chickens
yeah this is big plate chicken wow that
smells good mmm
yeah that comes with it linger there we
go a noodle oh I want one of those kinds
know that one's been sitting below that
weight on the chicken got it I got it so
malicious looking right okay
[Laughter]
whoa the noodle itself is very dumpling
don't we like and it's soft and that's
like you're eating a dumpling in one
noodle it really is like a soup at the
bottom I know why I think it's because
the noodle is your spoon it's say that
thank you so much see the peppercorn
here all going in oh that's so good
really okay do you like to do it yeah
yeah it sit on the pump the heat builds
a little bit the numbing peppercorn
asaro event yeah the addition of
cinnamon is really surprising and
delightful but arrival of Malaysian
cuisine a lot of the dishes there are
literally marriages there's no better
description of this than a marriage of
dishes it's delicious I get it I get why
they say stop noodling around cuz it
takes a long time to eat a noodle that
it sometimes when you get out of a movie
and you're like I don't know what to say
like when you finish a good book and you
just need to like take a walk in and do
nothing or like one and a half hour
drive across Los Angeles all the way to
Beverly Hills because that's where we're
going next but before that happens new
fact historians believe that Chinese
noodles originated more than X years ago
in the Han Dynasty what is X I don't
know how old the Han Dynasty is fifteen
hundred years ago now double that and
add a thousand four thousand four
thousand years ago I wonder what the
first shape was you've learned enough on
hand and without of that before yeah
what was the first noodle shape Oh
noodle shade yeah
noodles and noodle making stem from the
ripping of whoa okay going crosstown
make no sound now I headed to crustacean
a landmark Vietnamese American spot
we're gonna be having ons famous garlic
noodles and on top of that Dungeness
crab the noodles are a creation of the
founder of the restaurant lean on and
she's kept the recipe secret so they are
made in a seafood kitchen and we can go
in there we'll be speaking with chef
Tony and maybe he can spill the beans on
these noodles that's okay I mean Oprah
actually filmed here and she wasn't
allowed in there so we're pretty much
Oprah
I understand that your kitchen operates
somewhat in the secret somewhat yeah we
have a kitchen within the kitchen
that kitchens for family members and
people that have worked in the
restaurant for over 10 years why my boss
chef Holly nan she first started way
back in the 70s in this little deli and
slowly putting Asian flares here and
there she knew she was on to something
so she wanted to keep it within the
family we have about four items that
come from seeker Hitchin only the garlic
noodles have been around since it wasn't
open she saw that everybody loves
spaghetti and like Parmesan so that was
her inspiration she was just named the
mother of Asian fusion this is the
signature dish of the restaurant Asian
fusion has been looked at in a variety
of ways where I grew up it was looked
down on but you're doing Asian fusion
and it's right here in Beverly Hills how
are you able to put the narrative of an
Asian fusion food I think it was just
something cool for people to hate on
fusion but the way I became very
comfortable at it is when I spoke with
Eileen she didn't really know what
fusion was he's like I just cooking the
way I want to cook now if we're grabbing
from different regions of the world as
long as you're doing it intelligently
the end result should be pretty tasty
and so this is our last stop in our
video it's the three dollar signs but
the noodles themselves are not really
the expensive thing here right generally
if you're getting a crab you're always
getting a garlic noodle but there are
two separate items on the menu I would
say 99.9% people that get the crab they
always get Anu to enjoy the noodles to
their best this is not a question you
have to get the crab haha gotcha yes
whoa this smells like my fire alarms let
they go off look at that it feels like
something you shouldn't do at a
restaurant that's nice but I do just
want to go oh man that's so awesome
actually it makes a lot of sense here we
go here we go
ah there's the head of garlic takes
about 2 seconds 1 crabs in the shell and
one crab picked up the stone no in bibs
no way yes this is way more simple than
I thought
right Cheers
[Music]
oh yeah it's really good ah I just want
to eat this whole bowl ha it's so fluffy
was she your Luffy your noodle I'm gonna
do a little bit of crab is the life free
picked crap
[Music]
it's really good right this is my
fantasy as a kid of what a dish it
tastes like this is so close to the
buttered noodles we eat as a kid where I
add on the best version of a buttery
thing buttery crab meat pre-paid crab
okay is like birds who get to eat with
it's already been chewed up for them by
their parents talking about when a mama
bird chews up food and then throws it up
into the chick wings mouth the idea of
having food prepared for you it's a
mother's love right it's great now how
do you make it that's the question long
noodles a long life long day that's what
they say one thing that was your
favorite things that was not a noodle
today the noodle extruder at laucher
noodle house that was like a
old-fashioned manual train cart at
crustacean below the floor there's a
fish tank and there's a lot of beautiful
koi fish living down there okay Andrew
which noodle was the most worth its
given price I'll give a honorable
mention to the hats ear noodle from Laos
sure my worth it winner is gonna go to
Dolan's Weger cuisine oh my god oh my
gosh I can't believe it we agree for
once
I love crustacean and I was gonna say
Lau sure because the vast experiences
you get in one Bowl I wasn't winner goes
to Dolan's we de cuisine Adam who's
you're worth it winner Annie who's your
favorite noodle from today and Yi D
while we're in the neighborhood that
does it for episode 2 and our
end-of-year miniseries come back next
week for a very crispy conclusion nASA
has soft ends oh come on Adam
[Music]